مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا الان للمسيارات الاوكرانيه بحسب
الروايه الروسيه والتي تقول يقول يقول
الدفاعات الروسيه قامت بتعطيلها والتي
كانت تستهدف اغتيال الرئيس الروسي بحسم
اعانه موسكو اذا
لم يكن بالكريم من وقت محاوله الاغتيال
وتقول ايضا اجهزتنا الدفاعيه قامت بتعطيل
مسيرتين هاجمتها
ينشروا صورا لبوتين وهو يعمل بعض الهجوم
الاوكراني وهذا ما سنشاهده بعد قليل
الكلمه ايضا يقولون لم يصب جراء الهجوم
على مسيرتين وايضا موسكو هددت بانها سترد
على محاوله كييف الهجوم على الوقت والمكان
المناسبين اذا معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه
هذه الصور الاوليه لعمليه اسقاط المسيرات
الاوكرانيه التي حاولت مهاجمه
نذكر مشاهدينا بان موسكو ايضا اعلنت انها
منع الطيران المسيرات
العاصمه بعد محاوله الهجوم الاوكرانيه على
اتهمت روسيا اوكرانيا بمحاوله الهجوم
بمسيارتين على الكلام الاغتيال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ونشاهد الان اذا
هذه الصور
لعمليه اسقاط المسيرات الاوكرانيه التي
يقول الكلمه من انها حاولت مهاجمته
لاغتيال الرئيس الروسي لكن
الدفاعات الروسيه قامت بتعطيل هذه
المسيرتين او هاتين اللتين حاولت الهجوم
على بغرض اغتيال الرئيس الروسي بحسب ما
افاد
نواصل معكم مشاهدينا متابعه اذا هذه الصور
الاوليه لعمليه اسقاط المسيرات الاوكرانيه
التي حاولت مهاجمه الكيلو ونذكر ايضا بان
موسكو قالت اجهزتنا الدفاعيه قامت بتعطيل
مسيرتين هاجمت
ايضا بنشر صور لبوت وهو يعمل بعد الهجوم
الاوكراني ايضا يقول نابوتين لم يصبر
الهجومي على
مسيرتين وسنرد على محاوله كييف الهجوم عن
بالوقت والمكان المناسبين مشاهدينا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات